When we are debugging, we proceed the very same way.
Indeed, we're treating bugs as if they were natural phenomenon.
So, our hypothesis would be grounded on the initial observation of the failure
and possible also all the knowledge we do have about our program.
The failing run, more runs, the original failure, program code--
all of these goes into our forming a hypothesis.
At the end of the process, we get a consistent description of how the failure came to be.
We don't call this a theory. Theory is a bit far fetched for a simple failure.
Instead, we call this a diagnosis of the original failure.
It may sound a bit far-fetched to apply a method
that has been devised for studying natural phenomena
and for coming up with theories about natural phenomena on something as artificial as bugs.
However, errors and nature have something in common, none of them are under our control.
And the scientific method is precisely the method which you need
for explaining something that is not under our control.